Judge Jeanine is this the breaking point
well I think it is a Breaking Point and
the amazing part of it is this is New
York City how many people live here
eight million people we have one of the
biggest budgets for a city in the
country and we've got 61 000 immigrants
illegals here and and mayor Eric Adams
that you can't wait for him to rise to
the occasion is moaning and moaning
about the fact that that he can't afford
it if you can't afford it mayor Adams
what about the 5 million have come
through in the last year and have
destroyed the southern border and the
ranches and how dare you even consider
putting these people that are unvetted
we don't know who they are we don't know
what their real names are they not even
given an alien registration number
they're just being released on mass into
the public and you want them near near
our kids are you kidding me how far is
the gym from the school and I'll tell
you what you know it is it is it's about
time New York City and the liberal
Democrats experience what the rest of
the country has been experiencing we're
not just bringing the border to the
north now we're bringing the border into
our schools we're throwing out veterans
we're throwing out people who have
wedding plans we're throwing kids out of
school it's like what we did with the
baby formula we've got baby formula on
pallets but for you American citizens
you're not at the border illegally
you're going to have an empty shelf and
you know what make up your own formula
if your kid ends up in the hospital
that's on you I'm sick of this they're
Hypocrites now he doesn't want New York
City to be a sanctuary city are you
stupid did you not know what you said
when you came into New York when you
said we should protect our immigrants
New York City will remain a sanctuary
city under the Adams Administration
English is your first language you
should know what this means I wonder
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
comment commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now